I got diagnosed with strep throat the
other day and I thought I had the corona
virus and I thought how funny would it
be if the first case of the corona virus
in Los Angeles was a guy who would win
on his podcast and said I am for the
corona virus
I want the corona virus and then the
next day I got diagnosed with it but it
was only strap so I'm I'm better now
sort of my voice is coming back
I hadn't had strep throat since I was
like 10 that's something you get when
you're 10 and you don't realize like
being sick is fun when you're a kid it's
fun for at least a few days you can sit
at home you can watch movies back then
we went to Blockbuster and I'd rent
movies get a bunch of movies watch them
over and over again my grandmother would
make me french toast and grilled cheese
being sick was good but when you get
older you know it's it's hell you know
because there is no fresh house encroach
I mean there's nobody's making you
anything
nobody cares even if you're in a
relationship or something they don't
care they they're at work
nobody nobody has the time to when
you're sick when you're older give a
[ __ ] about you that was the whole thing
like when you were younger people used
to go I'll shut down or your
grandparents didn't have to cuz they
were they weren't working they were like
yo just come here and you can be sick
and we'll get you better and we feel bad
for you and you want to get movies and
what do you want to eat you know but
shred man and when you're a kid you
don't you love like a sore throat it
sucks but when you're older and you have
that strep throat and you just open your
throat and you're staring at the back of
your throat and you're like there's a
virus in me there's something in me I
mean it's
hard to swallow and you go eventually
this is what esophageal cancer feels
like it's just every sickness when
you're over 30 is just a rehearsal for
the big one and you don't know which one
that's gonna be and you don't know when
it's gonna be but every mild discomfort
you have is a rehearsal you know every
headache is a rehearsal for the tumor
that's the way I think every sore throat
is a rehearsal for the cancerous polyp
you don't know when it's coming but you
know it's coming it's a fact of life
every respiratory infection every
wheezing especially if you were smoker
it's preparing for when the doctor has
you in the office they call you in that
little office he goes hey here are the
options what a sentence here are the
options you know it's coming uncle uncle
of mine just got diagnosed with throat
cancer you know great great dude didn't
really smoke you know how to but
occasionally you know and so every
sickness you get past a certain age it's
so funny it's one of the things in life
that completely goes 180 degrees the
other way being sick as a kids kind of
like fun I mean don't tweet at me and be
like it's not fun for Kayla who has
leukemia I'm not talking about that not
just I'm not saying that
please don't tweet at me it's not you
know who's gonna insured little magical
I get I right I'm not saying that I'm
saying when your [ __ ] sick as a kid
and you get out of school it's fun but
when you're an adult it is not fun
because you're just thinking about okay
dodged a bullet
every doctor visit over the age of 30
you're dodging a bullet that's all
because we all know the stories now we
all have enough stories now you collect
them as you go through life and you're
in you're in your teens you have very
few yes people die but it's vet
the Y is very apparent they got in a car
accident it was a DWI it was an overdose
somebody got shot
it's very cut and dry as to why this
happened and your 20s it might get a
little murkier like but you still kind
of know you know it's like five brain
can't it's a rare and you're 30 is
people dying to just go haha oh that's
something something something not good
just these things start to happen as you
get older every decade it gets a little
bit less surprising you know 40s is a
decade of like yeah the guy just had a
heart attack at Runyon hit his head his
head on a rock
heart attack didn't kill him but hitting
a head on a rock that my friend told me
that story the other day 40 year old is
a guy a guy got a two-year-old daughter
just being I'm out done heart attack
head on a rock didn't die from the heart
attack died from me
hitting the head on the rock and running
you know like two people in Runyon
Canyon died every week yeah people don't
talk about it so I'm not trying to make
you in a hypochondriacs I'm just saying
that life is too short to not be hateful
you know what I mean people people don't
understand life is too short to hold it
in the bile the bile that courses
through your veins like that goo that
ran through the sewers ghostbusters -
it's too short you gotta let it out you
gotta have a group of friends where you
can let it out you have to hate the
right people for the right reasons you
gotta hate the right things that's why I
hopefully you listen to the program
because I do a lot to help direct your
anger into the right places where it
should go where it's productive but life
is just too short you're gonna go it's
coming it's gonna happen sooner than you
think
and you know spend your time on this
planet airing out your grievances I'm
telling you you're gonna regret it spend
time on the planet letting people at the
hotel front desk know the showers not as
warm as you would like in fact you'd
like it hot
and it's not what you consider hot have
the engineer go in there and check the
room you only get so long on this planet
let the waiter or waitress know exactly
what you think in the club sandwich if
the bacon wasn't crispy enough let them
know don't hold it in that when you hold
it in that becomes cancer let it out let
it out I'm telling you I went to the
urgent care to get diagnosed surge
occurs quick you're in and out boom boom
boom
it's what I'm into I like the urgent
care because I feel like if I go to like
I still like a real doctor I'm gonna die
cuz they're gonna really look at me you
know they'll really figure out what's
going on and it's the last thing I want
so urgent cares quick no I don't think
any of them are real doctors they're all
like UCB improv kids that are pretending
to be doctors the urgent in urgent cares
that they urgently want you out of the
office it's like a five-second diagnosis
in an urgent care they're like hey
what's up you like I'm bleeding they're
like a scream here's a script and go and
now that we're in LA you know and the
and the ticket ticket sells by the way
slow it down a little bit because of the
corona virus so I don't want the half in
half out and I talked to Ben about this
are we really gonna sell these shows out
we're gonna rock out we're not gonna
give a [ __ ] or we're just gonna what
we'll stay in the [ __ ] you know in
the bunker but I'm not interested like
half full theaters of people coughing I
want all in a roll out like people are
like oh that the last episode you were
saying you want a pandemic I'm like
here's what I want
I wanted it we're in or out I don't want
anyone losing money but if we are me and
Ben have spoken about listen then we're
all just gonna stay in for a little
while that's all that's what I was
trying to say I'd rather not I'd rather
not people lose money out there you know
but I don't want a halfway thing where
it's mostly hysteria and you know
everybody's losing money for no goddamn
reason
um but we're in the urgent care and now
the urgent cares job is to just tell
everyone going to the urgent care that
they can't test for coronavirus the
whole urgent care goes listen if you're
concerned about coronavirus you have to
go to the ER we do not have the means to
test you here so literally people walk
in and they're like hey I want to be
tested for come on and by the way people
know symptoms yeah there's no one cares
these people have no symptoms they just
simply want to get tested I just want to
be sure I'm like what what so you have
those idiots go and so I go and I go in
Monday morning and Monday morning my
throat I can barely swallow pain I mean
bad my tonsils are huge feels like I
have an abscess in my throat and it's
like you're like [ __ ] so I walk in
monday and I go hey they go okay think
of you traveled out of the country
recently I'm like I went to Vancouver
aa few weeks ago doctor goes okay and
then I went like I wasn't even thinking
I went to the doctor thinking a lot of
Asians though and she liked pretended
not to hear it yeah she like ignored it
she was still looking at the chart like
I was trying to balance cuz I was like a
Vancouver a few weeks ago she'd probably
yeah that wasn't okay I'm like eh but I
want to be honest a lot of Asians over
there again not being a racist trying to
get all the medical information to be
accurate I want you know and she's like
listen it looks like your strep test is
positive and I was like [ __ ] yeah thank
God I was like that's good right
she goes yeah yeah I guess I go yeah it
is
you know so then they give you a steroid
shot in your ass I don't even know what
that does it's supposed to calm your
[ __ ] you know I don't know what it's
supposed to do but it I guess the
steroids you know they're supposed to
help I think it boosts your immune
system right whatever you still feel
like [ __ ] right maybe they were the
right steroids it's also an urgent care
that could have pretended to do it they
could have just pricked me with a pen
and not done anything what you know I
they're probably just kidding fake
steroid shots so I go to CVS and I my
throat is like just okay and I'm
coughing a little bit cuz you can't
really swallow in the water it's like
what is almost aspirating out of your
mouth it's horrible
and then everyone at CVS is looking at
ya you know me a Ben just had lunch at
the Beverly Hills Hotel that was
coughing at the table and everybody's
looking at you like [ __ ] is this the guy
is this patient zero
is this the guy who brings it to LA is
this the guy that brings it to the
Beverly Hills Hotel this [ __ ]
right now